I'm Baauer.
And I'm Rosa.
And you're watching...
...Music Talks.
Hey everybody, we're Music Talks, we're here with Baauer,...
...we're gonna sit down and ask him some questions.
How are you doing?
Good, how are you?
I'm good, thanks.
Alright so,...
...could you have imagined the kind of attention you were gonna get from Harlem Shake?
No, definitely not.
When I was making it, it was just for fun, just fooling around...
...and I had no idea we'll get that kind of crazy attention so it was definitely a surprise.
That will be a good surprise, right?
Yeah.
A very good surprise.
What's your favorite part of the production process?
I like searching for sound or samples to use,...
...looking for a crazy sound that I have never ever heard used in a song before.
That's my favorite part.